hey it's evan and every week i'd like to
do a video to thank the people in my
life who have had an impact on me helped
me get to where i am and help me
continue to grow
both personally and professionally and
today i want to thank you guys
my audience
you guys have helped me so much i
remember when i first started this
business of helping entrepreneurs it
wasn't a business when i started it it
started by doing presentations and i
remember
what fueled me going through
each day
was seeing the feedback that came back
from you guys and i know it's hard being
an entrepreneur and you can have a great
day this is my problem i had a great day
i might do a presentation meet some
entrepreneurs
really help them one day have a
fantastic they go to bed like feeling
amazing like i really helped some people
today feeling so good about myself like
everything was right in the world and
then i woke up the next day and it's
like i had to start over from scratch
the motivation was gone the high was
gone
and i had to motivate myself to get out
of bed and do something
what really helped me
in those early days
was
i at the end of my presentation i used
to keep a feedback form i gave it out
and said what do you think of the
presentation
and there was always a section where
people would leave their own comments
and the comments were so profound they
were so impactful
and reading them
if you read about how you've changed
somebody's life
it makes you feel good right it makes
you want to do it again
and so what helped me get through the
the down days when i wasn't as motivated
was i would read the feedback again
i would read
the feedback i got from last week's
presentation
and know that i really helped people
like i really had an impact on their
life
and then that makes me want to do it
again
i wanted to go out and do it again and
again and again and that got me
motivated
and so it's all you guys and today
you know i still need it i don't wake up
every morning super high charged ready
to go yeah let's take on the world hey
maybe my my son had a bad night and last
night you know he woke up at one in the
morning and i had to change him and
clean him it was a long night rough day
i'm waking up this morning i had to go
to the dentist you know it's like
lots of bad things all at once
and then i got to get on and do 14
videos recording answering your
questions
what helps get me excited every day and
motivated to keep doing it
are your feedback
when you guys leave comments below like
the best part of my morning i wake up i
grab my water i get my lentils and
spinach and hot dogs and mix it all
together i sit down in front of my
computer and i start reading and
responding to my youtube comments
i love seeing the comments because you
guys write great things and it inspires
and encourages me
to keep going
and we all need that
and i'm lucky enough now to have a big
enough base that i don't have to read
the same comment over and over and over
and over again
it's always new stuff coming in but if
you're just getting started up and
you're having a hard time staying
motivated and excited about your
business
then look at the people you've helped
read the emails that have come in and
see how you've helped change their lives
now if you're not doing something that
is changing their lives and it's time to
do something better
but if you really believe in what you're
doing
then you've helped people
and seeing their feedback will help keep
you motivated
so two tasks for you two important tasks
for you this week
one
you know how much the youtube comments
mean to me
it means a lot to all of the content
producers that are out there okay a lot
of people who are just getting started
they don't have as big an audience as i
do
and they may not get any comments on
their videos
and they may see that and get
discouraged and quit and your comment
could be the difference between them
continuing to do something today or not
or shutting down their whole business
really it's that important so if you
like something on youtube if you're
watching a video i'm not talking about
like the stupid cat videos
fine but if you're watching something
from somebody who's poured the heart
into something and it's had an impact on
you just let them know
let them know because that could make
the difference today for them continuing
on with their company
and second your second bit of homework
number two is thank somebody in your
life recognize the people who are making
an impact on your business in your life
who encouraged you to keep going
encourage you to keep trying to push
yourself when you thought about quitting
they were there for you
thank them it'll make you feel good
it'll make them feel good and more
generosity will come to you
so thank you so much
believe
if you guys like this video you know the
drill thumbs up below and hey you know
how much comments mean to me so please
leave a comment under the video let me
know what you think
let me know if you have a question for
your business i'll do a video response
thank you so much and i'll see you soon